Speaker 1: Donald Trump did not stay
home over the weekend and he gave what
I can remember as the most deflated, low
energy speech of his political career.
Donald Trump actually gave two speeches over
the weekend. He went to Georgia and spoke to
the. Publican convention there. And then
he flew to North Carolina and spoke to the
Republican convention there. I have never seen
Trump like this before. Completely deflated.
I'm just going to play some clips for you.
These are only from his North Carolina speech.
The Georgia speech was less remarkable in a sense.
So we will just give you a sense of what was
discussed and even the crowd like not really big
other than when Trump said anti-transgender stuff,
which we will get to. Here is Donald Trump
just sort of ranting about how he went to
UPenn and saying, look, they indicted me.
Speaker 2: They indicted me thinking I was
a very good student at the Wharton School of
Finance. Can you imagine? I wonder if they're
proud of me. I got indicted. I wonder if they
say, Oh, that's wonderful. I've been indicted
twice now in a couple of months. You know,
when I was studying and when I was a very,
very successful businessman. And then I did The
Apprentice and I did lots of books that were big,
big, big, big sellers. Yeah. Even now I have
books that are tremendous sellers. I never had
I never had this stuff in mind. I never had the
word indictment. Which indictment mean? Sure,
that's fine. You're extremely dishonest, sir.
Speaker 1: So as you can see, blabbering and
blathering aimlessly and it only got worse. Trump
talking about Ron DeSantis criticizing him. And
I guess the crowd sort of like this. I don't.
Speaker 2: Know. If I weren't leading, we wouldn't
be talking about it, but we're leading by a lot.
We are leading just sanctimonious by massive
numbers. He's he's heading south quickly. No
personality. You got to have a personality to win.
He's got no personality, you know, And, you know.
Speaker 1: I mean, even Trump's heart doesn't
really seem in this ridiculous speech. And
I'll tell you, if I was under the indictments
that Trump is under, I wouldn't be able to go out
there and give nice speeches and be upbeat. Like,
I actually get it. I actually get it. But this is
important in order to understand that the things
Trump saying about, oh, this is going nowhere
and there's nothing here. This is very serious
stuff. And Donald Trump knows it on some level.
TRUMP Same is saying that now. It's actually
hard to say. DeSantis because he's gotten
so used to using the nicknames for DeSantis.
Speaker 2: That means we're leading Ron just
sanctimonious by 56, 69% for Trump, 13% for
DESANCTIS and Pence has six. You know, once you
get used to saying The Sanctus, it's hard to say
to Santos, I was actually being interviewed.
I was trying to be serious and I called them,
dissect this. I said, That's not good. But he's
changing his name, you know, now it's de Santos.
And I put a little message out, Never change
your name in the middle of the campaign.
Speaker 1: I have to admit, that actually is
funny. It seems one of the stupidest things you
can do if you're trying to get name recognition
is pronounce your name two different ways.
DeSantis and DeSantis Trump. Trump. Actually,
in the midst of all the legal chaos, able to put
together a little kernel of good political advice.
Donald Trump then seemingly unable to stop talking
about massive dumps. I know, guys, it's it's hard
to believe he's at it again with the dumps.
Speaker 2: But we can stop them cold and we
will. And we would have had him stop cold. And
they know that. And they cheated like dogs. They
cheated like nobody's ever cheated.
Speaker 1: Like a dog.
Speaker 2: Or you turn on your television at
10:00, you would have said, Pennsylvania's a lock.
We were up by so much a lock. All of
a sudden, you see that big fat dump,
that big dump at 302 or whatever it was in
the morning. It's a disgrace what happened.
Speaker 1: Beautifully put, right? I mean,
truly a wordsmith. It's it's beyond parody.
Trump then talking about how there is
a taint in New England. It's a taint.
Speaker 2: Such a big, big business, such a
powerful business and such an important business,
New England as a liberal tent. But or taint I
would say taint is a better word, right? But
it's a little bit on the liberal side. They say
it's such a big, big business, such a powerful
business and such an important business. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Okay. Trump talking about the CNN town
hall. And this was building to the highest energy
moment of the night, which of course, was an
anti-trans moment. Like, it's almost like you're
not going to get the crowd riled up about tax
policy. You're not going to get the crowd riled
up about getting people health care or dealing
with the environment. You're going to get people
riled up with anti-trans stuff. But in the midst
of that, Trump commenting on the CNN town hall.
Speaker 2: New England.
Speaker 1: Sorry, what? This is the
wrong clip. Here's the correction.
Speaker 2: Did you see the town hall with CNN?
They got one of the highest ratings they've had
in like 11 years. And they ended up firing the
guy because it was Trump who said they should
celebrate. We had our highest ratings. You're
supposed to get paid for high ratings, Richard.
But they had one of the. Highest ratings
they've had in many, many years. I was on
with a young woman who was I said, nasty. She was
a very nasty woman, but it worked out very well.
And they were all going. He owns you. He owns
you. Get them off the air. They're screaming. AOC
is screaming. He owns you. Get them off the air.
Stop it. Stop it. But you think if they had high
ratings, that would be a big he should ask for
an increase and said they fired him because I was
allowed to put across our point of view. It's out.
Speaker 1: There you go. And now you can see a
guy using his smartphone to film Trump.
Trump's entire speech just it's all so
depressing. Here is the highest energy
moment, and this won't surprise you.
Trump's highest energy moment was when he talked
about anti-trans stuff and he even acknowledges,
Wow, people really like hearing this nonsense in.
Speaker 2: Critical race theory, transgender
insanity, and other inappropriate racial,
sexual or political content of our children.
Speaker 1: Standing ovation at.
Speaker 2:
It's amazing how strongly people feel about
that. You see, I'm talking about cutting
taxes. People go like they're talking about
talk about transgender. Everyone goes crazy.
Speaker 1: That is incredible.
Speaker 2: Five years ago,
you didn't know what the hell it was.
Speaker 1: That is an unbelievable
statement. Trump is really summarizing in
that statement the absurdity of his own
movement. They don't care about actual
policy. They care about trans culture,
war anti-woke nonsense. This is a revelation
about what is animating the right today.
Trump says, I talk about taxes. People barely
clap. I talk about the trans stuff and people
go absolutely crazy. This is the monster they
built. And the question now is whether this is
a monster that can get them a president in the
Oval Office. I hope and to some degree believe
that the answer is no. All of these clips will be
available on all of our various platforms YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram, TikTok, etc.. Make sure
you're following us wherever you like to
consume your video content. We're going
to take a quick break and then continue
our coverage of this completely absurd,
farcical weekend in American politics.